well police say the victim is believed
to be a man in his 20s he was in the
road when he was found with injuries
consistent with being struck by a car
police say he was taken to umc where he
was later pronounced dead
just because i personally don't know the
person it's heartbreaking to see it
happen bo jordan is a personal friend of
the man who died he says people need to
slow down especially when driving
through a residential neighborhood
because usually because then just like
such a straight path
people use it as like a straightaway
just fly just so they can see how fast
that car goes for a few times which can
cause accidents leaving family members
behind to bear the burden i see when new
someone gets it i'm like wow that's
unfortunate but having it happen to
someone so close to you it's like it
hits a different part of your heart and
he has these words of advice for the
driver who killed his friend honestly
from what had happened
just turn yourself in for it because
there's no like i don't know i don't
really have any bad words it's just
what goes wrong comes around and it's
gonna happen sooner or later
now neighbors tell me that speeding
through the streets without speed bumps
is a constant problem throughout the
area along with the lack of flashing
stop signs at night from the newsroom
jeremy j ford live local now